with the olympic opening ceremonies in
tokyo coming up this friday
we are introducing you to athletes who
are pushing the limits and inspiring the
next generation of champions
the u.s olympic and paralympic museum in
colorado springs showcases america's
greatest athletes
and their gravity-defying achievements
some iconic olympians spoke with cbs
this morning saturday co-host dana
jacobson
telling her how their journeys taught
them lessons that go beyond sports and
dana
is here and joining us now good morning
dana good morning vlad the museum
focuses on the core values of the
olympic and paralympic movements
respect inspiration equality and courage
and shows that beneath every olympian's
determination and excellence
there's also a story of resiliency and
perseverance
it's a great dress and it served me very
well
that's an understatement yeah at 19
years old
american figure skater peggy fleming
gracefully glided toward
gold at the 1968 olympics in grenoble
france
wearing a chartreuse dress made by her
mother
they make a chartreuse liqueur up in the
mountains
in grenoble and she thought well if i
wore
the color chartreuse it would endear me
to the french people
and they would applaud more fleming's
iconic dress
is among the memorabilia on display at
the u.s
olympic and paralympic museum in
colorado springs
it's a wonderful place to kind of let
your dreams
just explode of could i really do this
but
all you have to do is try and you
sometimes surprise yourself
the museum also features i think i left
early interactive exhibits
i've lost to jesse always like a virtual
race against
four-time gold medalist jesse owens
on the day we visited we even ran into
retired hockey player jim craig
the goalie for the 1980 gold medal
winning team usa
best known for their improbable victory
over the soviets
the miracle on ice this is a real
special place that is a really really
special place for anybody
because somebody's going to leave here
with an ambition that he didn't have
before they came in here
it's a history museum it's a cultural
museum it's an
art museum it's a museum that talks
about social progress
we talk to athletes all throughout the
process michelle dusser farrell a vice
president at the museum
helps create exhibits to honor athletes
and highlight their stories
including her own that's my leotard we
wore that in the team final
she took home silver at the games in
1984 as a member of the u.s gymnastics
team
the stories of both olympic and
paralympic athletes
exist here at the museum side by side
this isn't here's a wing of the
paralympic games
this is equal and on par
we're one team our athletes are the
fabric of our nation
we want everybody to see that our team
represents this nation
this is also personal for you beyond
your
olympic time how i have a daughter who
plays wheelchair basketball
and so she now is seeing athletes that
represent her journey her experience
in this museum and being inspired by
that as well
we hope that the stories through sport
that are told here
are really a platform for telling a
bigger more global story of
pursuing your passion working hard
overcoming obstacles
a 17 year old miss from colorado springs
peggy gail fleming peggy fleming faced a
major obstacle
after winning her first world
championship in davos switzerland in
1966.
two weeks later her father suffered a
fatal heart attack
that really shook my world and my mom
had to raise
four girls by herself and then my
expensive sport
it was just amazing what we went through
and how my mother was so strong
when you lose a parent you lose that
strength
and every time i'd go back to try to
train i'd go i'm not as strong
as i was before he died and then over
the
months and years it all came back
helping
catapult fleming to the top of the
skating world
her story one we all can learn from
when somebody comes in here and reads
about you reads your story what do you
hope they walk away with
i just hope that they can put themselves
in my shoes and
put themselves in that story you just
never know
until you try a sport or try something
to see where you stand it's not for just
a special few
it's for everybody to try and then let
the fire fuel you
oh absolutely absolutely at the museum
some of the employees have disabilities
some are aspiring paralympians again
this museum is taking those core values
inclusivity and equality to heart and
actually showing them off
fantastic playstation it's beautiful it
really is and boy i still remember peggy
fleming winning that goldwin
i know i think it was the only goal the
u.s won in 68 right
right she looks fabulous yeah she looked
great i fangirled out on jim craig i got
it
like my smile was that like oh my god
it's jim craig
i love seeing michelle's uniform i
remember in 1984 mario
that team that was when we were kids
that was a big deal
peggy's fleming's advice all you can do
is try all you can do no matter what it
is